well just here at the chongqi
the legends of the 10 rings world
premiere red carpet
my buddies
yo great guy about the real rejects
john somewhere he's back there
so literally just came out
shangti of the premiere it was
it was a crazy movie it was one of the
best movies
from marvel um they did something real
different with shanghai
and
it's it's insane the post credit scene
in the mid credit scene will blow your
mind
and the movie is visually kind of insane
and
not what you expected
and overall it's just fantastic i'm here
with with some fantastic people
greg alva john real rejects here's
brandon davis right there comicbook.com
gave us awesome gift bags and
i really can't explain
how much i love this movie it's by far
one of my favorite marvel movies right
now and kind of just in general my
favorite one of my favorite movies in
general and i say that reservingly
because i realize i'm at the premiere
and it's very exciting but
it
trying to be as subjective as possible
it's an amazing move and i truly truly
did love it visually it's a masterpiece
and
it's just so cool it's just
it's amazing
see you guys woof